coup d'accélérateur pour les carrières
de dominique fortier et de marié petiote
elles sont en lice pour deux des prix
littéraires les plus prestigieux de la
francophonie les villes de papier de
dominique fortier est nommé sur la liste
du prix renaudot toute une surprise
c'est quelqu'un qui m'avait tagi sur
facebook pauvres est en disant bravo
félicitations du sénat mais non cette
personne se trouve c'est une heure à
rejeter encore incrédule et je le suis
encore un petit peu pauvre et le livre
s'inspire de la vie de la poétesse emily
dickinson dickens ncc une existence qui
est uniquement centré sur l'écriture où
il n'y a rien d'autre que ça y'a même
pas le besoin de reconnaissance de deux
super appli écrivain cg c'est quelque
chose de très très peur je ne jouais pas
stains su qu'il était amoureux de sa
tante la trajectoire des confettis et le
tout premier roman de mariage tu as tu
un départ fracassant après avoir
remporté plusieurs prix au québec et les
sélectionnés en france pour les prix
médicis et pour le prix de flore aux
côtés de ses idoles tendance réelle de
voir mon nom aux côtés de ceux
d'emmanuel carrère chloé de l'ong qui
sont des auteurs que je lis depuis des
années puis j'apprécie beaucoup la
trajectoire des confettis un livre
ambitieux qui atteint sa cible
c'est un roman choral l'e-book
personnages donc on parle d'une histoire
à l'autre ça retient l'attention
et puis je pense que j'aborde aussi des
thèmes et thèmes contemporains
elles vont rejoindre petit cercle de
grande écrivaine canadienne qui ont
réussi à se tailler une place au sommet
de la littérature francophone mondiale
il ya eu des marie claire blais qui a
remporté le médicis on a eu un hiver
gabrielle roy qui ont eu non seulement
une carrière incroyable mais qui ont
aussi obtenu le femina on a entonné
mallet une acadienne qui a obtenu pour
pélagie la charrette en 1979 le goncourt
on connaîtra le nom des lauréats au
cours des prochaines semaines mais peu
importe le résultat
pour mariette chiottes et dominique
fortier c'est déjà un excellent premier
chapitre ici nabi alexandre charti radio
canada montréal